thank you so much for being here today
and with us at the summit we are
thrilled to have you thank you so much
for having me of course so I think I
want to start off by asking you what
experience or Insight made you want to
become a singer
oh my gosh
um
they're easy
I believe that I was just talented I
grew up
singing like it's not something that I
can say and there's something that has
pushed me to become a musician at an
early age I was already singing and I
knew exactly that I want to be a singer
if not so uh an actress I remember even
at school my teacher if she was asking
so what you want to be and I would I
would say I want to study music and my
class would laugh at me and be like hey
when you don't study music blah blah
blah and or all to realize that later on
when I was in joburg that actually why
they were laughing at me because you can
study music so it has been my thing to
to be a musician and where where I'm
where I I believe that I belong you know
yeah yeah I love hearing that yeah and I
want to talk a little bit about growing
up I know you said you know you were in
school but I won't talk about how
growing up um where you grew up and how
that affected your music
um
I believe it does because
um you know if you listen to my music it
is very
there's so much soul in my music maybe
if I didn't grow up the way I grew up
maybe I was going to sing without
um a putting soul in my music and also I
was I grew up a church so I I love God
so much you check my music every time
I'm always talking about God as much as
um with my music you find it at clubs
people love it at clubs people love it
at church this is the music that you can
listen to while you are with your
grandmother you are with your kids you
know there are no swearing in it so yeah
I I and I I thank God for that because
my music is loved by everyone
yeah it's amazing
um now I also want to talk about the
rise of afrobeats because for us in the
US you know it's it's pretty new the
rise of afrobeats okay style of music
yes it's pretty new for us and I know it
is not new here yes um but it's it's
growing globally and African music is
becoming so popular throughout the rest
of the world why do you think that is
what's what's contributed to the rise uh
I I think this is time okay for for us
Africans to show the world that
um we are not uh chanters we are really
talented and I I did say on uh on on my
previous uh interview that uh thank you
so much to social media as well because
it is giving us a chance to spread our
music for other people to see what we
are all about because maybe if it wasn't
for social media maybe our music wasn't
going to be able to cross the board so
because sometimes also you find that
maybe they are not playing our music in
their radio stations but then because of
social media you find to talk in South
Africa you find Tick-Tock in America you
find Tick Tock all over so that way it
is for us for them to
see our music whether I'm a piano or
afrobeats makes a lot of sense I know
social media here has is just starting
to come out of being just about friends
and family and finally to be about
building a brand yeah and becoming a
Creator or a musician how has it been
for you have you been able to find
lucrative deals from it or how have you
used social media to build your brand
um I've I I found a a recording label
before social media
um but what it has done for me I believe
that today Jerusalem song is over 500
million views I believe it's all because
of social media that's why it has been
traveling you know because you check the
song no one doesn't know the song
honestly speaking you go to Nairobi you
go to
um Mozambique you go to Kenya or you go
to
um Jerusalem everywhere I believe it's
all because of social media so yeah
I I believe that social media really
playing is playing a a huge role and
nowadays we really need to pay attention
to it and I I want to go back to
Jerusalem because that is the Hot Topic
with you right now what did that song do
for your career and are there any doors
that it opened oh my gosh
that's why I'm here today that's why I'm
sitting here with you you you guys and
I've got so much respect for Forbes and
um if maybe it wasn't for
um Jerusalem or maybe I wouldn't uh be
sitting here I know that after Jerusalem
I I did a big song as well that
um got me a creamy award I've been being
been working hard for myself but
um there's so much that this song has
done for me I've traveled the world
um yeah I don't know what else but I've
traveled over here yeah yeah yeah and I
want to end with just something and
maybe some advice you can give to people
what do you wish you had known about the
music industry that you know now oh my
gosh you wish you known when you were
starting you guys
such a difficult question
oh my gosh
um
yo
this industry is very tough
you need to have a crocodile skin so
this is something I didn't know earlier
I was thinking that it is just smooth
you know but now I know that if you are
not if your eyes are not open
hey baba you'll cry so you really need
to understand that the the music
industry is business
because also you know with us musicians
sometimes we think that it's all about
singing playing blah blah blah we don't
understand that this is business you
need to really respect it respect your
craft and it can take you very very far
if you respect it and this is what I'm
doing now you'll never find me and maybe
being late in my shows or maybe not
pitching up so I I understand that I
need to respect this this is business
for me that makes sense well thank you
so much I appreciate so much bye